hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play this stairwell
okay now this whoa what the hell why is
that on the ceiling huh wait a minute
where am I now this is a game by the guy
that made scp-432 oh okay
it's just it's not stairs on the
ceilings this is um I don't know how
closely this relates to scp-087 which
was the first SCP that got turned into a
game I think but I have to I have to
believe that there are got to be some
parallels to it but anyway it should
prove to be pretty interesting because I
mean this guy has scared me before so I
can't imagine that he wouldn't do that
now I think it's Mota's most recent game
along with scp-432 I'm not sure but
we're gonna find out I hear some wind
I'm sure I'll hear and feel a monster in
my face at some point and if you didn't
know I've actually beaten se p o8 seven
the one made by the same guy that made
SCP containment breach you can find it
on my channel I was done on a livestream
someone paid me to do it
and I finally did it but it's like a
two-hour long video it took me
well that's not right who's singing is
it the siren song to call me to my doom
probably I don't like the stairwell game
I got used to it after a while because I
understood how the scares worked and I
was able to kind of plow through it
without getting too affected by it out
towards again but when I didn't know
what was going on it was probably one of
the most scary games going on the
scariest games I've ever played so I'm
kind of apprehensive to go down this
okay
long stairs now it seems like the stair
length changes randomly don't know why
don't know
for what purpose maybe this is like the
first guy that found the SCP oh eight
seven haha hey no uh-huh not gonna get
me no cheap jump scares will get me too
brave for that gotta do more than that
anyway this might be the first guy that
found the SCP and before the the
foundation managed to make a containment
facility around it hi is it getting a
bit more staticky on my camera it might
is Slendy down here is Slendy gonna jump
out at me I hope not why is my reticle
blinking now come I split that take a
picture
come on running low on batteries or
something or has it always been blinking
not sure I have no idea anyway not a lot
going along not a lot going on that I
can tell
it's kind of disconcerting and I'm it's
really strange it's really strange that
the stair sizes are so sporadic and if
something is changing it's very subtle
like the sound I'm talking about if
something is changing in the sound it's
very subtle I sprinted all no I cannot I
swear it like like the edges of my
vision are slowly very slowly getting
closer together and the static is very
slowly getting more profound all I can
really do is just keep moving forward or
maybe I'm just going crazy it has it has
it always been like that or is it just
new it's got to be new it's got to be
new it's got to be new I really don't
know what to expect besides that face
but that face did remind me of the face
that's reported to be in SCP Oh 8 7 ok
long staircase
I got this ringing in my ears now I
swear I didn't hear that before but now
there's a ringing in my ears
okay is something gonna happen is
something gonna happen
you're killing me game come on do some
do some I don't like apprehension do
something just jump out at me scream at
me do something do some game oh I can't
move my mouse whoa who the hell was that
I don't know I don't know I don't know I
don't know I don't know I don't know
this will be a bad time for my wireless
mouse to die as I'm wandering through
these stairs okay is something gonna
happen or am I just gonna have to lay
the smackdown on whatever ghostly
ghastly thing is in this place I don't
have time to mess around with you I'm a
busy man with a busy life and a busy
schedule
nothing's happening why is nothing
happening why is nothing happening do
something don't do something I changed
my mind I don't want anything what's
gonna happen is there something behind
me what's happening it's definitely more
staticky you can't fool me now it's more
data gap paying attention now what was
that what is it what is that I don't
know I don't know ah this is tough don't
do anything I change my I don't want
anything done I don't want anything done
I don't hunt anything good uh wait I
mean the perspective is like going
different it's I can't describe it but
it feels like I'm going up and steadied
down now I don't know why I can barely
see anything where's the stairs where's
the stairs where's the deer stalkers I
don't like this I don't like this any at
all what the hell is happening to me all
right
just got to keep moving downwards the
static is almost permanent now huh what
the hell
well something happened things are
moving around on my desk
not sure what Oh what was that I don't
even know what do I even think of that
you know this static is gonna rain this
is gonna be hell on my rendering but
what what the hell is going on
that never happened in SCP Oh 87 I don't
even know what that was
anyway let's just calm down here I
believe that this is randomly generated
of some sort of some sort it's gotta be
the stairs are just interspersed and it
can't be like an infinitely long
staircase it's got to be written
randomly generated to some extent
procedural procedural generation what is
called I can buy my mouth dad stop stop
it maybe that's what happened I got
flipped around when my mouse gets stuck
like that and suddenly I was going up
can I go up I don't even I can't hunt I
can't go up it won't let me yeah well
love it it's got a gap back I'm going to
have and it's so going to pass
is he gonna do some don't do nothing
uh-uh I can't help but smile cuz this is
fun this is not fun no this is fun
I like that no I don't like this at all
you shut up you shut up Oh everyone's
seeing my masochist just masochistic I
like being scared side Oh No thank you I
don't want any oh hey you go to hell and
you die unless I'm already in hell than
just the dying part do that I really do
like horror games I don't know if it's
just like generally over time I get a
love of them after playing it for so
long every single day a new horror game
it's just fun you know you get your
heart rate up shots of adrenaline good
times good times
scarred memories total insanity it's fun
it's fun good good times
I think the static has reached its peak
a long time ago I'm not sure I'm not
sure what more is gonna happen to my
camera besides the total inverting of
the world
it's just this constant sound of ringing
in my ears making me paranoid I guess
that's a good thing in horror games but
I want something to happen okay maybe I
lied the static seems to get it getting
more extreme like a lot more extreme
like seriously there's gonna rain for
rain hell on my rendering because
rendering does not do static well
because when it tries to compress here's
a little science with Mark bar when it
compresses it compress it doesn't
compress well when you make a video it
doesn't uh
I knew something was gonna happen as
soon as I turn it it sounds like oh god
he's talking about video compression I'm
gonna kill you right now
you're so boring oh well I'm still here
hi hey hey buddy you're alternating
between a skull and a a pretty lady face
maybe I'm not sure hi can I move oh what
can I move I can move oh okay I thought
it was a go just go hi I died again I
double died maybe I'll supposed to turn
around and run up the stairs I didn't
think about that okay I think I'm
definitely dead now super dead I was
dead in the real world and then I got
killed in the spirit world game over all
right then haha maybe you guys can give
it a try and see what happens for you
guys so I have no game over question
mark oh gosh but anyway that was pretty
fun I actually quite I actually quite
enjoyed that you know I do like scary
games they're fun they really are I like
him a lot so you guys should give it a
try it's pretty fun game just pushing
yourself down the stairs it's such a
simple concept but it can really rain
hell on your psyche so give it a try
everyone should enjoy that one so thank
you everybody for watching thank you sky
midnight roof
another game so thanks again and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
ah [ __ ] Oh
Oh
blood
oh damn it